right now what ivanka is trying to show
here is that if the white king steps to
the side just clearing the first rank
just so there's no checks later on uh
from the black queen then after the
black rook comes across
everything now ganged up against this
lone pawn this white pawn is now about
to drop then white can create a
checkmate threat what can bring his rook
up and now we see why white's king is
not on the first rank because if the
black queen takes it's not check and
white will actually soon deliver
checkmate and okay
this didn't happen this would have been
very safely met by black's rook coming
back across but if we catch up with the
current position we did see a trade
white was sick of defending his pawn and
now queens are off is completely
balanced let's go back to the players i
think we'll see a draw any moment
black has won his pawn back anish giri
saved this game
and we're headed to blitz
position repeat itself there we go check
it's a draw yeah it's gonna be blitz tie
breaks between these two starting 15
minutes after the final rapid game in
this round has